[Music]
all right you guys have had seen that it
made no sense
have you guys seen this new tick tock
where this baby got thrown into a pool
yes swimming training or something right
yeah actually sign on times page first
and I was like what the [ __ ]
chunked in it yeah they just jump it and
the baby goes in for like four seconds
and then comes back up and floats yeah
it's like survival tactics for babies
who knows that kind of natural baby Navy
SEAL training no baby should ever have
to experience this eliminate all that
info and just view this video for what
it is it looks [ __ ] wild can I go
home and do it attack immediately no
because hey something don't go big baby
well I didn't see this one this baby has
got it gone
trained like for two months oh so you
have to reach a certain level of
training before you do this baby I can't
watch these no I can't watch these fools
chuck them in there oh that's awesome
good job buddy
that's so cool swimming yeah that way if
they ever fall in the pool II don't know
that's amazing look like a baby no more
I know from the head first the music -
it's all intense different videos of the
singing that's awesome
I can't do it what it scares you yeah I
hate it I get it
they don't even know to hold their
breath in the ticket breath no they do
no really didn't you have that kind of
swimming lessons yeah but not like that
didn't chuck him in no it was literally
like tick I'm just holding in there just
getting used to the splashes hold him by
the leg and that is dropping I like how
it looks like you're at a river and
you're just throwing long you can visit
Krista with her two boys and her husband
he looks like he liked the water so she
posted on her tik-tok that video the
first video that we saw and she
captioned it with it says all of her
amazes me every week I can't believe he
is barely two months in and is catching
on so fast he is a little fish hashtag
baby hashtag swim this went viral it
currently has 5.1 million like hearts
how dare people being yeah I saw I saw
Twitter poses I should Chuck him in
there like a [ __ ] bath bomb drop them
in there like a bet I'm more delicate
with my bath bombs than that lady was at
the bait and what it's flushing a few
had lost my dog more delicately than how
she handled that baby yes oh so the
instructor is actually like a family
member like a felt like a relative who
is a trainer at this particular facility
where they do this like survival like
would you Oh was saying the survival
baby swimming yeah it looks super dope
like just in case the baby falls in that
they're able to know how to roll on
their back and float so they could
breathe and stay alive and so for like I
said earlier for these babies and the
people who actually conduct these
programs they say do not just [ __ ]
coldly go in there and throw your baby
in the water they need to have
screaming yes exactly because a lot of
people like parents especially like in
our generation and before they think
like oh you need to learn how to swim
and they just push them that's how I
learn people are lucky that it's these
people doing it cuz if Bart was doing it
he'd be like your baby needs to know how
to how to get into a pool if they got
there from a helicopter yeah right
that's exactly why they they so that one
video where she brought them in they're
saying that they're trying to train
these these kids to be prepared for any
type of fall so from that that's why
they're doing them like a different way
because it's like in case they fall from
a boat yeah that's why they're doing it
but the people like the people who
actually created this program they're
like that's too much like really that's
an unrealistic situation like there's no
reason why a kid would fall in also with
that amount of force like that's not a
natural fall because they're saying that
the reason why they're throwing them in
the first place is to cause like
disorientation so they know how to come
back up to the surface and breathe but
the people who actually created this
program are like perfect baby where they
throw the baby off the trampoline and
see if you can get into the pool on the
other side I do miss but you don't see
those or a human cannon baby okay
they're like a cannonball sighs right
it's like a circus boom
yeah we have a friend who has a kid
that's a few months younger than tyka no
cake she just turned one so he's like a
whole [ __ ] almost two years on and
now because he went through that
training like now he can just jump right
in and then he just knows to come back
up and just chill which is great which i
think is super dope but we we've watched
the progression of it and like the first
couple of classes the baby that's choked
on water a little bit and then it cries
so it feels bad but for me I guess as a
dad I'm like I think this is dope I
think it's worth going through that pain
to have a baby that's like drown proof
or whatever yeah I get it - and I get
Gio - so I'm kind of in the middle I
don't know if I could I don't know if
you did fall in the pool you're thankful
that he did the training
Yeah right that's why for me I'm like
I'm just gonna put a [ __ ] fence
around my pool but the father situations
like you know vacations or whatever yeah
I mean he's gonna wear to life vests and
I'm gonna be tied to him
nice Wow you're gonna pull them down
yeah if I die he dies with me well I
mean it's a good thing I think now by
Tycho's age like he can actually learn
how to swim instead of doing this cuz
this is probably baby babies yeah so
months just to me that one I imagine
this I imagine him like in a 90s shitty
or action movie with a knife in his
mouth like one of those skits that we
did the [ __ ] uh let's have some fun
that one the attacker should be Rambo
for Halloween this year
plastic knife I know be way badass a few
stick onto a pacifier girlfriend nice on
with the pacifier
do is he's always like ten months old to
me he doesn't have a taller body no more
he has a [ __ ] 30 year old man with a
mortgage body by now dude huge yeah
that's true she went straight to dad bud
no he does not have a dad but he's got a
six-pack and little pecs terrified yeah
I can't do that man I can't like just
[ __ ] crib training or having him
sleep on his own and him crying I was
already like I [ __ ] hate you have you
guys seen that actually in in real life
they were doing that kind of training in
real life not have you seen it in real
life no before me like as in like in
front of me yeah oh no oh because when
you mentioned your neighbor I thought
that day our friend we follow them on
Instagram and they were showing the
progression like every single week Wow
yeah what are the first lesson yeah cuz
I for me okay like fear sometimes can be
based on that creatures experience of it
right so like a dog might be you throw
them in there and they're like well it's
not scary or whatever right and in a
baby I think a lot of times humans
they're taught fear or trauma based off
of how the parents respond to what's
happening
so if the baby thought this was playtime
and they're not reacting in a way that's
traumatic is that a bad thing but I
don't know so that's why I posed that
question because if the baby's having a
traumatic time I think that's that sucks
for sure so when I was very young and
stupid I was a young mother okay be easy
on me but we had a pool and so when
Isaac was like nine months old or
something we had like the little like
[ __ ] floaties thingy they heat like I
put him in the floatation pool available
for me to look around like the ring
thing around Lodi that you just stick
the baby inside so he had one of those
and so we'd be swimming all the time and
in like I would kind of like splash
water cuz even went bad like this kid
was always like terrified of water in
his face and so we'd always got good
like if he's gonna drown always and so
I'm like well my thinking was like it
might just get him the right used to it
I don't remember in the rain but I he
probably would have been cuz it was so
extreme so like I thought like maybe
exposure therapy right so I would like
splash water on his face like or like
grab water and like trickle it down he's
sobbing like if I was murdering him and
I'm like come on you're fine or whatever
and then like I'll take him out of the
floaty and I'd hold down I'm like come
on like you just [ __ ] warm up to it
but no it literally never worked and it
got to the point where he hated swimming
he hated the water and it took swimming
with Joe in Hawaii for him to get over
swimming literally
I don't know was that bad for him we
just had a fun time so it was so early
so before that he wouldn't because he
was just fine
oh I remember he was afraid of the waves
yeah yeah and it took Nancy to be on the
other side of the way and then from
there I didn't know he was that
terrified yes yeah like a phobia of
water oh we were having a blast no
that's why I was just cute I mean also
like I was so young with like very
little piece I don't think that's stupid
though yeah I don't know I think it was
mainly for lack of patience and lack of
understanding that I fault younger
Tiff's for because she ain't have enough
patience you probably did it so
aggressively and fast so it's not
exposure therapy in a way where you're
supposed to do it little by little yeah
but like where you just like drowning
his ass with buckets of water that's one
patient waterboarding or something yeah
like even in Hawaii like I'd just be so
annoyed where I'm like a fine that don't
[ __ ] come into the the beach then
like go over there and not have fun with
the sand and like I don't know I just
didn't know how to deal with it so so
not until then like when you guys were
swimming then he finally got over it Oh
interesting and then now you took he's
doing swimming classes he did yes he was
killing it with all his strokes and yeah
loves he loves swimming now like he
absolutely good the tough part with kids
too is sometimes you don't know if
they're over exaggerating in lying or
they're really afraid
cuz tyka like he loves water but there's
something about like water and his eyes
he's always scared of getting like soap
and water in his eyes it burned probably
at one point so he's like well I would
take my shower together he's standing
next to me the showerhead is over here I
turn on the water and he starts crying
and sobbing as if it's really in his
eyes so what were you saying that story
so um tyka definitely had something like
that like a focus where yeah where he
got scared and I remember the way you
did it with with Isaac where I was like
oh [ __ ] okay let me learn from Tiff's
story
sorry it's okay no no I mean it I mean
it just naturally happens you know I
just put soap in his eyes the shaman
really
no this is the real baby up you little
baby baby up I'll guard style no because
I remember that story I'd like backed
off and I let him trust me again so like
I would have to like back off and I
would like let him kind of go at his own
pace and that's kind of because of your
story I was able to like because I would
have done the same [ __ ] oh then you're
welcome Tyga ya know cuz that was the
part that I never let him and I'm glad
you learned because for me I just I
didn't understand that he no longer
trusted me so whenever we would go
swimming he would be upset with me like
so upset like I was his worst enemy she
the associated the trust with you and
the water
yes yeah cuz I guess they've just felt
like they weren't being listened to or
under like yeah I like Peter worse dude
yeah exactly
so um why this when he takes a shower
with me because I let him do it he
doesn't cry he doesn't for real I just
turn on the water he's having to [ __ ] me
onto a chef shower sure he comes inside
I turn on the water yeah yeah for me I'm
just like there's no water here you see
it looks down there and then he'll do it
and he's like oh [ __ ] okay second as I
hold up there's no water you put this
water in there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]